good morning John in the grand tradition
of people on the internet assuming that
others care about inane details of their
lives I have decided that today I'm
going to give you a tour of the inside
of my nightstand as ultimately this
probably says more about me than any
home tour or drugstore haul video ever
could first we have my iPad which I use
as a slightly more convenient and
vaguely futuristic way to look at tweets
I did this more when I kept my iPad on
the nightstand but then my son turned 2
and transformed into a monster that
screams for 15 minutes every time he
sees an iPad so now I have to hide it
okay sure this is just trash an octopus
and a dollar I got these after my
eardrums ruptured during a flight
because I had a sinus infection but I
have not had to use them since so I have
no idea if they help granny potty mouth
gave me a business card so big that it
is obviously a postcard there are
actually lots of business cards in the
drawer I like how she's just sort of
vaguely gesturing at a cloud of pink
stickers here this is a bunch of lens
cloths that I got from an optometrist
fan on tour I never clean my glasses
though because as previously mentioned I
am oblivious to everything more stickers
oh my god I'm only two burritos away
from a free burrito I had no idea this
was in here oh god this is the list of
people I need to write thank you cards -
for helping move my book in one way or
another now I'm stressed out just
knowing that it exists yawn sorry is
actually something it should be in here
it's nice to have a notebook here are my
notes for my Creator track keynote at
VidCon Australia last you this is a fart
noise machine gentlemen 39 year old man
and I can't bring myself to throw away a
fart noise machine it doesn't even have
batteries another sticker I'm pretty
sure that this card was supposed to give
me access to FX's streaming platform but
I could not be bothered to type in the
code anybody else want it okay here are
some more stickers cables cables cables
cables cables cables cable what the
Frick is this one for hens fence fence
fence fence fence fence bends fancy pen
and you know here two of the most
complex and astounding objects ever
created by humans that I threw into a
drawer because I was done with them and
I couldn't be bothered to spend 20
minutes finding them new homes I'm a
terrible person I have heard that
everybody wants a rock to wind a piece
of string around so I have one of those
oh my god Gilbert you might be thinking
right now that's actually the first
enamel pen we found don't worry I keep
them all on this snitch witches box
everybody should have a snitch witches
box for their enamel pins look at them
all I don't have a problem hey if you're
into a nail pins in one
help support the work this community is
doing to decrease maternal mortality in
Sierra Leone the pin Club is open for
just two more days $12 a month free
shipping anywhere in the world these are
the dice I used in Titan's grave so I'm
glad I had somewhere to put them I
didn't lose them look at them yeah
memories oh great a cufflink
I definitely cufflinks and this is a
shoelace just getting to the dregs now
these frickin things does anybody use
these the only thing they do is go and
freakin drawers alone loose puzzle piece
I'm sure that's not a problem and this
freakin piece a useless metal the Mike
government is too busy being terrible to
not get rid of cool cool cool so what
did we have 22 business cards and one
business post card to flash drives eight
writing utensils one D 22 lip balms and
some cold sore medication a bunch of
earbud replacements and other ear things
six miscellaneous peripherals one recipe
for pot roast a bunch of actual trash
seventeen stickers of four cards two
daddies so many cables one dollar and
sixty cents in like twelve hundred
dollars of electronics so now how's
about we make some actual decisions
because I'm not a child
[Music]
oh god that feels so much better
except for Frankie fine you go back in
to again it's your last chance to sign
up for the dftba bizarre beast spin pal
Club John I'll see you on Tuesday